[Música]
y
de aislamiento preventivo obligatorio
aislamiento selectivo con este anuncio
empezaron la semana los colombianos una
nueva fase desde el 1 de septiembre en
la que comenzará la reactivación de la
economía han sido 152 días de
aislamiento en una de las cuarentenas
más largas del mundo y ahora tras
superar el pico es momento de recuperar
la salud mental para ello está previsto
entre otras actividades que vuelva a la
cultura desde el 14 de agosto el
gobierno de colombia autorizó la
reapertura de cines y teatros para ello
los locales no pueden superar el 50 por
ciento del aforo deben dejar 2 asientos
libres entre espectadores y por cada
fila ocupada ha de quedar una libre unas
medidas que serán verificadas por el
ministerio de salud sin embargo todavía
no se han visto espectadores en el caso
de bogotá a la capital colombiana
el jueves termina la cuarentena por
localidades pero por el momento los
cinéfilos y amantes del teatro tendrán
que conformarse con los autocines
[Música]
el río de janeiro han abierto los
principales puntos turísticos como el
pan de azúcar y el cristo redentor
pero los teatros y los cines siguen
cerrados hubo un intento de reabrir los
embajador 20 de agosto pero finalmente
las autoridades locales dieron marcha
atrás por el repunte de casos de
coronavirus tampoco es sanpaolo que es
la capital económica y cultural del
brasil han reabierto los teatros y los
cines los empresarios del sector del
cine reprochen al ayuntamiento que no
haya formato de un estudio que demuestre
que una sala de cine más peligrosa que
por ejemplo un gimnasio o un centro
comercial ambos abiertos desde hace
semanas los teatros por su parte creen
que podrán recuperar la programación
normal sobre el año que viene y están
preparando algunos espectáculos
en lo que se está teniendo éxito en todo
brasil en las principales capitales del
país son los rabinos eso es sin
al aire libre donde los usuarios pueden
acudir en coche y ver una película desde
la seguridad de su coche
i
[Música]
en uruguay le abrieron las alas resines
con la proyección de una película por
día también bajo estrictas medidas
sanitarias lo hicieron museos centros de
espectáculos musicales y teatros
allí productores y actores debieron
apelar a su creatividad para adaptar
guiones al distanciamiento físico mínimo
de 2 metros entre los actores la mayor
dificultad para las salas de cine ha
sido la falta de estrenos a nivel
mundial así como también un máximo de 30
por ciento de espectadores en relación
al aforo habitual de todas las salas de
espectáculos haciendo que éstos muchas
veces sean inviables económicamente
entretanto quienes también apelaron a la
creatividad fueron quienes abrieron tres
autocinemas donde allí el público
concurrió en gran medida
[Música]